sens public notre édition spéciale
consacrée au rejet de la loi immigration
à l'Assemblée continue débat 100 %
politique que je vous propose maintenant
avec des parlementaires représentant les
partis Renaissance LR Europe Écologie et
ver et rassemblement national on va
parler notamment un thème que j'ai
volontairement évité dans cette première
partie on va parler notamment d'une
hypothétique dissolution de l'Assemblée
mais d'abord on va évaluer les rapports
de force dans cette commission mixte
paritaire qui se profile à l'horizon
avec
Adrien l'avenir du projet de loi
immigration repose sur une commission
mixte paritaire elle réunira H8 clos 7
députés et se sénateurs leur mission
s'accorderit sur un texte commun ils
partiront de la version du Sénat durcie
par la droite en novembre les sénateurs
LR compent bien camper sur leur position
nous travaillerons sur la base du Sénat
et du travail fait par le Sénat qui
avait fixé des lignes rouges une
stratégie globale à laquelle nous tenons
énormément c'est à la majorité
présidentielle de faire en sorte de
faire l'effort et que Monsieur Sacha
lier ne prennent pas le Parlement en
otage dans cette commission mixte
paritaire Renaissance et centristes ne
disposent pas de majorité ils ne
pourront rien obtenir sans les voix des
qu LR à l'issue des discussions l'aile
gauche du camp présidentiel pourrait
refuser de voter le texte s'il remet
troup en cause l'intégration des
travailleurs étrangers pour le chef de
fil des sénateurs socialistes il y a peu
de Chan que le texte évolue est-ce qu'il
peut évoluer en CMP je n'y crois pas
trop à moins que LR fasse un cadeau au
gouvernement mais s'il avaient vou faire
un cadeau il l'auraiit fait déjà hier la
commission mixte paritaire pourrait se
tenir dès le début de la semaine
prochaine le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin souhaite que les mesures
du projet de loi soit adopté d'ici la
fin de l'année pour le Sénat l'heure
n'est pas à la précipitation que si on
se réunit sous 48 he 3 jours voire
qure il y a assez peu de chance pour
qu'on trouve une solution personne n'a
de majorité au sein de la commission mix
paritaire donc faut qu'on discute les
prochains jours seront CR pour l'avenir
du texte le centre et le camp
présidentiel doivent encore poursuivre
leur tractation avec la droite et la
gauche comment Emmanuel Macron peut-il
sortir de cette crise politique n'est-ce
pas le moment de redonner directement la
parole aux Français Gérald armanin
est-il trop fragilisé pour trouver des
alliés pour relancer cette PL
immigration quelquesuns des thèmes il y
en a beaucoup on en débat avec Marc
ferci bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes député
des Français de l'étranger
vice-président du groupe Renaissance à
l'Assemblée nationale François Noël
buffet bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous
êtes sénateur les républ du rô et
président de la commission des lois
manie Vogel bonsoir et bienvenue
sénatrice écologiste des Français et
Français de l'étranger co-présidente du
Parti vert européen meric durx bonsoir
vous êtes sénateur rassemblement
national de cemarne Marc fer je commence
avec vous c'est une claque pour le
président de la République c'est un
échec évidemment c'est un échec on
s'attendait assez peu à cette motion de
rejet à ce qu'elle soit
adoptée on a pu constater qu'il y a une
alliance assez cont natureat entre des
groupes qui ne pensent absolument pas la
même chose sur les imigration des gens
qui veulent la limiter de manière très
drastique c'est à la droite et à
l'extrême droite et puis des gens qui
sont beaucoup plus ouverts avec une une
appétence assez faible pour la
régulation
d'immigration tout le monde s'est
cristallisé sur ce texte donc maintenant
on a une responsabilité collective c'est
quand même de faire passer ce texte qui
est attendu par beaucoup de Français
parce que si on prend l'intégralité des
mesures qui compose ce texte que ce soi
les mesures de ce qu'on peut appeler le
volet régalien celui qui vise à expulser
plus facilement les les étrangers
délinquants à faire quitter le
territoire à ceux qui n'ont pas leur
place sur le territoire ou le volet plus
centré sur le travail et bien on voit
que les mesures sont populaires on voit
que ces mesures correspondent le plus
souvent à des constats de bon sens qui
proviennent du terrain mais elles ont
mis la
majorité en en grande difficulté à
l'Assemblée alors en difficulté vis-àis
des oppositions mais on n pas découvert
cet état de fait hier nous
sa nous sommes en major éé relative nous
avons déjà connu des défaites nous avons
perdu des votes déjà à l'Assemblée parce
que nous sommes en majorité relative
nous savons que quand les oppositions
sont à la fois unis et mobilisés ce qui
était le cas hier cétait très mobilisé
et bien nous perdons c'est aussi simple
que ça c'est mathématique c'est
arithmétique c'est ce qui s'est passé
hier maintenant je pense que ça n'est
pas la fin de l'histoire une CMP on va
en parler a été annoncée elle va se elle
va se passer dans les dans les prochains
jours moi j'espère qu'il pourra qu'un
texte pourra sortir de cette CMP et
qu'un texte qui sera je l'espère votable
par les deux assemblées François Noë
buffet est-ce que vous approuvez la la
stratégie d'opposition frontal de vos
collègues députés de du parti je crois
surtout que il fallait réaffirmer le
fait que de l'attachement au texte du
Sénat en réalité la commission la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale avait détricoté d'ailleurs c
une surprise pour personne puisque le
président l'avait lui-même annoncé ENF
le président de la commission en
l'occurrence donc ça a été fait c'était
un signe qui ne marquait pas vraiment la
volonté de vouloir aboutir bon après
voter avec le rassemblement national
avec après on pouvait on pouvait
imaginer que le débat en séance
peut-être rééquilibre les choses c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'avait dit le ministre
d'armana en disant en séance on
rééquilibrera les choses ça ne s'est pas
passé donc il y a un point extrêmement
dur il faut donner toutes ses chances à
la commission mixpitaire je je
voudrais citer Churchill à cet instant
la victoire ne dure pas la défaite ne
tue pas il faut continuer donc il faut
avancer il faut que cette commission
mixte paritaire puisse se tenir je pense
dans un délai raisonnable qui nous
permette de travailler naturellement sur
la base du texte du Sénat Mélanie Vogel
vous vous espérreer quoi que le
gouvernement retire ce texte oui je
crois que ce qui s'est passé au fond au
moment de la motion de rejet c'est pas
une alliance contre nature parce que
c'est pas une alliance bah c'est un peu
quand même
ce les députés europolog ver on vé avec
les députés rassemblement national
pourquoi parce qu'en fait c'est ce qu'a
essayé de faire le gouvernement qui est
contre nature et qui ne peut pas marcher
vous pouvez pas mettre dans un texte ça
ne fonctionne pas il n'y a pas de chemin
pour que ça fonctionne un peu
d'humanité et puis un peu d'extrême
droite en fait les Humanistes ne veulent
pas du tout du tout des propositions
d'extrême droite et l'extrême droite ne
veut pas du tout d'humanisme donc vous
ne pouvez pas mettre dans un même texte
la régularisation des sans papier et
puis une politique plus dure qui expulse
plus qui supprime la me et cetera ce
n'est pas possible ça ve dire quoi qu'on
fait forcément de l'idéologie sur
d'immigration ça veut dire que le
gouvernement a essayé d'inventer quelque
chose qui n'existe pas c'est-à-dire
mettre ensemble des humanistes avec
l'extrême droite ce n'est pas possible
donc il faut choisir vous allez devoir
choisir et en CMP au fond c'est ça qui
va se passer vous allez devoir choisir
entre faire votre majorité parce qu'
aujourd'hui vous arrivez pas à faire de
majorité c'est c'est un constat le
gouvernement n'arrive pas à gouverner
vous allez devoir choisir entre faire
une majorité avec sur la base des
propositions d'lr et de l'extrême droite
qui se sur ce sujet-là globalement sont
assez proches ou de faire une majorité
je parle pas de Françis de François Noël
buffet personnellement mais globalement
sont assez proche ou faire une majorité
avec des personnes qui souhaitent
améliorer les conditions d'accueil et
les conditions de vie des personnes en
France et cette majorité c'est soit
l'une soit l' en même temps n'est pas
possible sur un texte répon de Marc
Ferti je vous donne la parole juste
après mais très rapide bah écoutez il
faudra que les gens qui ont rejeté ce
texte hier à
l'Assemblée et qui ont fait courir à ce
texte le risque de ne pas être adopté
aillent dans leur circonscription
expliquer pour ceux qui appartiennent à
la droite ou à l'extrême droite pourquoi
ils ont refusé les mesures du volet
régalien et pour ceux qui appartiennent
à la gauche moi j'ai passé du temps sur
le terrain à discuter d'immigration de
travail et les gens et les gens qui
appartiennent à la gauche et les
associations par exemple qui défend
prendre les 100 papier sont très
attachés à la mesure de régularisation
dans vousz expliquer à tous c à tous ces
interocuteurs n interrompre comment vous
vous allez expliquer justement vous et
puis les députés du rassemblement
national qui ont voté cette motion de
rejet à côté des députés LFI et EUR et
d'autres avoir refusé ce texte comment
vous allezexliquer très simplement ce
texte n'était ni fait ni à fait en
réalité quand il est sorti du Sénat en
réalité il y avait quelques mesures un
peu plus fermes qui aurait pu aller dans
le bon sens si ce n'est cet article 4
bis qui de tout de toute façon était une
pompe àante pour l'immigration même dans
même dans sa version revue par le scénat
évidemment parce que de toute façonprs
s'il vous plaît je vous ai pas
interrompu par contre je pourrais
revenir sur ce que vous avez dit puisque
vous avez dit que en gros les mesures
plus de fermeté étaient d'extrême droite
donc j'apprends que le peuple français
pour qui 80 % d'entre eux sont pour des
mesures beaucoup plus fermes vis-à-vis
de l'immigration et d'extrême droite bon
ça appartient ces proposl à Madame à
Madame Vogel mais en réalité nous
qu'est-ce que nous voulons nous voulons
un retour au peuple puis qu'il y a une
situation politique qui est bloquée qui
est figée avec une majorité relative qui
est disloqué avec une a gauche une a
droite qui ne parle plus je ne parle
même pas des républicains entre un
groupe ici un peu plus conservateur et
et des gens à l'Assemblée nationale qui
qui savent pas vraiment non plus dans
quel camp ils habitent en réalité nous
on est le seul camp véritablement soudé
avec une vision claire retour au peuple
dissolution ou référendum ce que
Monsieur Macron a refusé on y reviendra
disolutions référendum ça va évidemment
faire partie des thèmes de ce de ce
débat vous vouliez réagir François Noël
buffet pourquoi sur le texte le texte
qui sort du Sénat est un texte qui veut
une politique migratoire cohérente on a
travaillé sur des mesures cooheritives
c'est vrai de lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière mais on a facilité aussi les
procédures et simplifié les procédures
pour rendre service aux magistrats mais
également à ceux qui doivent bénéficier
de ces procédures et on avait tout un un
volet qui n'existait pas intégration au
départ qu'on a ajouté donc l'idée c'est
un équilibre donc vous
vous il y a la il y a de la fermeté elle
est absolument nécessaire aujourd'hui h
il irrégulière l'idée d'unetique
immigratoire choisie qualifié plutôt de
dominante économique avec une volonté de
réduire l'immigration régulière pardon
je dis les choses très clairement et et
il y a sur l'asile la volonté de que
cette procédure d'asile ne soit plus
utilisée à d'autres fins que ce pourquoi
elle est faite c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
beaucoup de réseaux de voyou utilisent
cette procédure pour emboliser le
système donc le système qui sort du
Sénat et le texte qui sort du Sénat est
un système équilibré ferme et juste mais
je m'inscris vraiment dans l'idée que on
a augmenté les moyens sur l'intégration
et la volonté d'avoir une intégration
qui soit réussie car c'est un échec
depuis longtemps il faut des choses
telles qu'elles sont alors deux deux
réactions sur ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée avec le le vote de cette
motion de de rejet d'abord celle du
président de République c'était en
conseil des ministres ce matin le chef
de l'État a dénoncé je le cite le jeu du
pire le cynisme extrême et l'incohérence
de deux partis qui se sont partager le
pouvoir pendant 40 ans les mêmes qui ne
sont pas venus à Saint-Denis fait
référence à son dernier rendez-vous qui
le avait qu'il avait lcé à LR et au
Parti socialiste au rencontre de
Saint-Denis ne s'y était pas rendu et
puis autre réaction celle du président
du groupe Renaissance à l'Assemblée
nationale on écoute Sylvain Maillard le
vote d'hier il a juste montré une chose
c'est que l'ensemble des oppositions
dans leur irresponsabilité ici ont
décidé de se payer le gouvernement je
crois que c'est très clair c'est ce
qu'on a vu hier quel est le rapport
entre Sandrine Rousseau qui vote avec
Eric cotti avec Mathilde Panau qui vote
avec Marine Le Pen c'est ça qu'on a vu
hier donc j'en appelle à la respons ité
de chacun des groupes pour qu'on puisse
trouver pour les Français une réponse à
au besoins de fermeté que que nous avons
et que nous ressentons tous donc nous
allons trouver nous allons travailler
dans les jours qui viennent là suite
Mélanie vel est-ce qu'il y a pas
effectivement une difficulté dans les
dans les qui se profile à l'horizon là
dans les jours à venir pour notamment
les députés de votre parti de justifier
ce vote alors non moi j'ai aucun probl
ça vous a pas fait mal au cœur de voir
les les députés colollgés vert voter
avec C du rassemblement la seul vu tout
ce que vous dites sur le RN depuis des
mois non mais bien sûr mais le c'est
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ce
que je disais au début il s'est passé
que c'est un texte au fond le
gouvernement se place toujours dans
cette situation personne n'est d'accord
avec nous la gauche est pas d'accord
avec nous la droite est pas d'accord
avec nous donc vous voyez on a raison et
il faut qu'on continue ben non en fait
le problème c'est que pour trouver une
majorité vous ne pourrez pas mettre dans
une même majorité les écologistes et LR
sur l'immigration ce n'est pas possible
donc si vous voulez faire un texte qui
trouve une majorité il faut choisir on
ne peut pas est-ce qu' y a
d'irresponsabilité c'était la critique
pardon nous interrompe c'était la
critique principale de ou en tout cas
l'axe de défense de la première ministre
à l'Assemblée cet après-midi taxant ceux
qui avaient celles et ceux qui avaient
voter cette motionget d'irresponsabilité
je trouve ça intéressant comme argument
de la part d'un gouvernement qui n'a
même pas voulu recevoir un vote de
confiance du Parlement et qui
aujourd'hui gouverne sans majorité
parlementaire et sans l'avoir cherché la
responsabilit elle est du côté du
gouvernement quand on est un
gouvernement face à un parlement où il y
a pas de majorité absolue ce qui je veux
juste le préciser dans toutes les
démocraties européennes est juste normal
c'est normal qu'on n pas de majorité
absolue on va aller chercher les
majorités de la coalition je sais je
sais mais en fait on a eu l'occasion en
2022 on s'est retrouvé face à un
parlement o il y avait pas de majorité
absolue c'était la première fois que le
gouvernement sur la 5e République avait
l'occasion de montrer qu'on était
capable de gouverner en France de façon
intelligente manque de bol il y
ils arrivent pas à trouver un chemin qui
met d'accord une majorité et après ils
disent ah ouais mais oppositions qui
sont responsable on narrive pas à
trouver un truc qui met tout le monde
d'accord c'est pas notre faute c'est la
à un moment donné qui est au
gouvernement c'est pas moi voilà donc
bien sûr que c'est compliqué mais un
moment donné je le répète il faut
choisir on peut pas avoir les
écologistes extrême droite sur un même
texte ce n'est pas possible on peut les
avoir tous les deux contre soi mais pas
ensemble avec nous Mar F qui est- IR
responsable dans dans l'histoire mais
nous dit finalement c'est le
gouvernement qui est pas qui a pas
vraiment tendu la main pour créer une
coalition déjà Sylva Mayer n'est pas au
gouvernement ça vous a pas échappé
peut-être que il sera un jour mais euh
qui é responsable déjà ceux qui ont
refusé le débat parce que il faut quand
même le rappeler écarter la motion de
rejet 493 c'est vous qui écarter la
motion de rejet ça veut dire refuser de
débattre pendant 15 jours c'était le
temps du débat qui s'annonçait devant
nous du sujet de l'imigration moi non
plus je vous ai pas interrompu donc si
vous le souhaitez euh moi je suis assez
stupéfait de cela notamment de la part
de partis qui ont mis l'immigration au
cœur de leur identité politique c'est
très surprenant de ne pas vouloir
débattre de l'immigration alors que vous
aviez 15 jours pour le faire c'est pas
très surprenant et en même temps on a
l'habitude à l'Assemblée nationale j'y
passe beaucoup de temps de voir le le le
rassemblement national ne pas s'exprimer
beaucoup donc l'irresponsabilité elle
est d'abord sur ce refus du débat je
pense que les Français attendent un
débat sur l'immigration et d'ailleurs
beaucoup de gens le demandent chaque
année qu'on ait ce débat sur
l'immigration là on avait la possibilité
de l'avir ensuite moi alors pardon je
vous interr dans la parole juste après
votre réponse là-dessus refus du débat
c'est vrai que c'est un thème majeur
pour pour le REM nationale débat été
tranché depuis très longtemps en réalité
regardez tous les sondages d'opinion 80
% des Français sont contre une
immigration de oui à quoi sert
l'Assemblée nationale si
vous la 20e loi immigration depuis s'il
vous plaît il y a une 20 mais bien sûr
que si vous connaissez pas ch 500000
immigrés par an lég plus plus les PL
écoutez il y a de plus en plus non mais
écoutez depuis 25 ans
l'imigtion00 par soit la ville de
Toulouse je crois que vous avez fait
pour Toulouse aussi donc il y a 500000
vous êtes voilà moi aussi d'ailleurs
donc donc de toute façon il y a un
consensus de la part des Français B pas
autour de cette table ben évidemment
mais là là je suis tout seul mais en
réalité parmi le peuple on est beaucoup
plus nombreux comme au Sénat on est on
est que trois mais peut-être que demain
on sera un peu plus nombreux mais en
réalité le débat il a été tranché c'est
pas qu'un jour de plus ou de moins qui
aurait fait ça le le il s'avère que le
gouvernement là on gouverne que avec ve
les sondages enfin vous êtes
parlementaires on va pas renoncer au
débat Parlement C il faut pasou de toute
façon il y a le processus législatif va
poursuivre il va y avoir une commission
mixte paritaire dans laquelle il va y
avoir aussi un débat si le texte repasse
et bien après il y aura de nouveau un
débat mais là je crois que c'est un peu
fort de café pour un gouvernement qui a
fait passer 20 493 qui tue toute forme
de débat parce qu'il n'est pas
majoritaire de dire qu'il n'y a pas de
débat dans les Mar fer et ensuite
Françis buffet vous reviendrait juste
après parce que vous étiez en pleine
démonstration sur les 493 sur des textes
budgétaires nous avons fait adopter tous
les textes qui était un texte budgétaire
formellement nous av nous avons fait
adopter tous les textes autres que les
textes budgétaaires sans recourir au 493
donc sur encore une fois sur ce cette
question du débat ça nous aurait permis
je vous donne simplement un exemple ça
nous aurait permis par exemple de
questionner cet argument que j'ai
beaucoup entendu qui est celui de
l'appel d'air l'appel d'air et notamment
l'appel d'air qui serait consécutif à la
mise en œuvre de l'article 3 devenu
l'article 4 bis c'estàdire celui qui
permet des régularisations dans les
métiers enenstion C appel d' j'en
entends beaucoup parler j'aurais aimé
qu'on ait ce débat pourquoi parce que
moi je me suis intéressé à toutes les
mesures de régularisation qui ont eu
lieu depuis Jean-Pierre chevénem sous
tous les gouvernements de gauche et de
droite et bien je universitaire de
profession je le confesse j'aime bien
qu'on documente un petit peu ces
arguments est-ce que vous pourriez me
donner un exemple une mesure de
régularisation qui a suscité un surcroix
d'immigration irrégulière ou régulière
d'ailleurs vous n'en trouverez pas vous
n'en trouverez pas don cet argument
allez je suis désolé mais c'est du vent
c'est ça que le débat aurait permis
d'expliciter et c'est pour ça que je le
regrette je le regrette qu'on ait refusé
ce débat hier à l'Assemblée nationale
Emer Duroc sur le l'appel d'air et
ensuite François n buffet moi je
voudrais poser une autre
question quelqu'un de votre majorité la
vice-présidente Naima mchou a dit que
justement elle reprenait une partie de
nos arguments en disant que ce texte
n'allait pas régler la question
deimmigration clandestine on peut citer
aussi le le cas de Monsieur Chel aussi
qui secrétaire général appel d' par que
vous n'z pas adressé un thème inessant
mais évidemment qu' y a un appel d'
c'estàd que si dans l'article 3 vous
dites jeis très bien si vous me laissez
parler je vais prouver si si vous dites
que dans l'article 3 et bien tous ceux
qui sont dans les métiers en tension et
bien seront régularisés et bien il
suffira qu'il y ait une filière
clandestine qui s'organise autour de ces
métiers en dention pour ensuite
régulariser c'est évident votre avis
là-dessus François Noël buffet et
peut-être aussi sur la notion de
responsabilité parce que pardon
peut-être aussi sur la question la
question elle se pose particulièrement
pour un parti qui a gouverné plusieurs
fois comme le parti enfin l'éraation
parti je pense le fait de refuser le
débat au Parlement quandme je pense que
rien ne remplace le débat et faire vivre
le Parlement c'est de débattre donc
regret
regret personnel j'assume j'ai un regret
bien sûr parce que je crois que le débat
est absolument nécessaire surtout sur un
sujet aussi important sur lequel les
Français nous attendre vous parlez tous
de sondage et vous avez raison c'est une
préoccupation importante mais on ne peut
pas régler cette préoccupation si on n
pas capable de mettre les choses sur la
table clairement et pas simplement de
parler par slogan ou par punchline et si
on va pas au fond des choses or on a
besoin la France a besoin d'aller au
fond des choses et ce débat à mon avis
il est absolument essentiel et votre
avis donc sur cette cette idée que
développait mari il y a pas d'appel der
modo l'immigration régulière régulière
aujourd'hui c'est peup à peu près plus
de 275000 personnes chaque année je
parle que de l'immigration
irrégulièreration irrégulière iment à
900000 personnes oui 900000 personnes
presque un million de personnes c'est
pas moi qui a inventé ce chiffre c'est
le ministre de l'Intérieur qui l'a
indiqué à l'occasion de des auditions
qu'on a eu ça ne cesse de progresser il
se trouve qu'ici j'ai un peu plus
d'ancienneté que les autres et j'ai vu
ce que l'évolution de l'immigration
depuis 2006 singulièrement effectivement
vous avez une augmentation d'immigration
irrégulière qui est très forte il y a
plusieurs raisons à ça c'est
multifactoriel ça tient la situation
internationale on a eu la période de
2015 bien évidemment mais ça tient aussi
à l'attractivité de la France
app a potentiellement j'arrive on a
potentiellement avec une mesure de
régularisation automatique le risque oui
d'une d'un appel d'air bon alors la
question étant après une fois qu'on a
dit ça c'est pas de dire on veut rien
c'est de dire on a besoin peut-être dans
les métiers en tenstion d'avoir une des
gens qui travaillent très bien on peut
l'imaginer mais on fait ça au cas par
cas ça a été la position du ce que vous
avez proposé après avoir retravaillé à
la loi Mog sur ce sur ce point précis
lequel métier entention appel d' Appel
d' alors là où je suis d'accord c'est
que c'est vrai qu'on a besoin d'un débat
raisonné avec des vrais arguments qui
s'échangent autour de réalité et pas de
fantasme quand on passe sa journée à
raconter n'importe quoi au français et
au français c'est vrai qu'après ça peut
se refléter dans les sondages je parle
pas de moi-même et je vous remercie de
me laisser continuer mon propos il y a
pas d'immigration massive en France
c'est pas vrai il y a de plus en plus
c'est vrai dans le monde il y a des flux
migratoires qui augment raison oui c'est
une réitéres Merz raison quand au fait
que vous dites n'importe quoi il y a des
flux migratoires qui dans le monde
progressent c'est le fait des crises
c'est le fait des guerres c'est le fait
du fait qu'il y a de plus en plus
d'université dans le monde et que les
étudiants bougent beaucoup c'est la
cause majeure de l'immigration
aujourd'hui en France et les étudiants
voilà donc voilà il y a pas une
immigration massive en France dans le
sens où la France par rapport aux autres
pays européens est plutôt moins
attractive que les autres pays européens
mais c'est comme ça c'est un fait ça
vous pouvez le regretter par vous pouvez
le regretter mais la France accueille
moins que les autres pays
européens elle ne prend pas sa part elle
a par exemple accueilli 3 et demi fois
moins d'ukrainien et d'ukrainienne en
fonction de son pb que les autres pays
donc d'ailleurs c'est c'est très marrant
parce que votre affaire de faudrait des
cotas chaque année en fonction de nos
capacités d'accueil si on faisait ça en
réalité on augmenterait le nombre
d'immigrés en France puisque on en
accueille pas assez et j'en vient à
l'appel d'air alors il y a pas et je
rejoins mon collègue ici il y a pas une
seule fois dans l'histoire de la vie des
politiques migratoires ni en France ni
ailleurs où on a pu constater qu'une
mesure qui avait été prise soit dans un
sens soit dans un autre avait un effet
sur les flux il y en a pas on a beaucoup
parlé de l'Ame par exemple laame c'est
un appel d'air et Cera et cetera vous
avez avec
laame les estimations basses il y a
environ la moitié des gens qui ont droit
à la me qui n'ont pas recours donc
c'estàd c'est l'appel d'air pour les
amnésiques hein ils arrivent en France
puis après une fois qu'ils sont là ils
ont complètement oublié donc c'est bien
la preuve que ils ne viennent pas pour
ça donc l'appel d'air n'existe pas il
n'y a aucun moment dans l'histoire des
politiques migratoires où il y a eu un
effet sur le fit migratoire d'une mesure
qu' entendu vos arguments au au autres
làus je veux bien vousonner la parole R
qui est à la tête de l'OFI il a produit
un rapport qui est très complet
là-dessus qui démontre à l'évidence que
l'attractivité de la France est réelle
et que notamment par exemple pour les
titres de séjour santé on a une
attractivité qui est très forte pour
d'autres sujets on l'a aussi quand on
parle des étudiants en 2017 le texte on
crée le titre pluriannuel de 3 ans qui
était dérogatoire par rapport à ce qui
était fait avant puisque c'était la
première année évidemment
automatiquement vous créez on une
augmentation effectivement des étudiants
en France je dis pas que c'est pas bien
d'avoir des éud la moitié de la ha c'est
des étudisou alors on on va y revenir
parce que moi y a un mot que que vous
n'avez pas employé mais que moi je vais
employer sur cette question là sur cet
article 3 la régularisation des des
travailleurs étrangers dans les métiers
en tension c'est le mot hypocrisie je
vous propose quelques chiffres ils sont
donnés par l'INC il concne l'île-defance
et je les ai trouvé dans euh ce nous
confire des échos articles qui datent
tout simplement de ce mardi matin en
Île-de-France 22 % des emplois occupés
par des étrangers en île-de-fance par
alors ça c'est le chiffre global 22 % si
on regarde les métiers en tenstion
justement Île-de-France toujours 44 %
d'étrangers parmi les assistantes
maternelles 50 % dans la restauration 60
% dans le bâtiment 61 % pour l'aide à
domicile benah on peut pas s'en passer
tout simplement Mar ferci non mais non
mais il faut le dire disons fr on a
besoin d'une immigration de travail ça
ne devrait surprendre ni choquer
personne quonque s'intéresse au fonction
du marché du travail constate dans tous
les pays et pas simplement en France
qu'on a la coexistence de gens qui sont
au chômage et d'emploi vacant un marché
du travail ça fonctionne comme ça et les
gens qui disent il suffit de remettre
les Français au travail on aura pas
besoin d'immigration c'est des gens qui
n'ont jamais étudié le fonctionnement du
marché du travail je l'ai fait pendant
une grande partie de ma vie
professionnelle je sais un petit peu de
quoi je parle
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on on en a
besoin en revanche en revanche ce point
que vous soulevez est un point important
euh une partie de l'opinion publique ça
a été dit et je rejoins certains des
constats à une vision très négative de
l'immigration une partie des raisons qui
expliquent cette vision négative est que
relativement aux autres pays et le
Conseil d'analyse économique le le
détail asse bien nous avons une
immigration relativement peu qualifiée
vous avez cité un certain nombre de
professions quide 2021 voilà et on a une
immigration relativement peu qualifiée
ça se traduit par lesour grâce à ces
étrangers peu
qualifi avec certains de mes collègues
j'ai milité et j'ai déposé des
amendements qui sont évidemment pas pas
examiné pour les raisons qu'on sait euh
visant à rendre plus attractif notre
système d'immigration qualifié
c'est-à-dire à faire venir plus de
talent avec une ambition qui est de
changer justement cette représentation
qui est aujourd'hui une représentation
négative en montrant que il y a des
bénéfices à l'immigration il y a des
bénéfices en particulier à une
immigration plus qualifiée et ça je
pense que c'est un élément qu'on
gagnerait également à poser dans le
débat Emeric Durox quand vous voyez ces
chiffres comment vous réagissez il il y
a ces secteurs quand on peut discuter
avec des chefs d'entreprise ils sont
très nombreux à dire mais on narrive pas
à recruter des Français pour ces postesl
tout simplement donc on va chercher des
travailleurs étrangers qui pour certains
sont sans papier B écoutez c'est tout le
problème il y a peut-être un problème
d'attractivité de ces métiers là vous
citez des ch moi aussi j'ai j'ai
d'autres chiffres par exemple et et je
pourrais même citer votre enfin le
président de la République Monsieur
Macron qui je crois de mémoire parce que
je l'ai cité lors de la discussion
générale sur le budget immigration
c'était le 27 octobre 2022 il a dit que
une très grande majorité des faits de
délinquence dans la rue était le cas de
d'immigrés d'immigrés donc évidemment
par rapport à à la vision négative
qu'ont les gensoui B cette réalité elle
elle existe la réalité du marché de
l'emploi aussi on peut pas gommer l'une
pour simplement l'aut sauf qu'on peut
aussi parler de ce de de ces cas-là et
et il y a un problème d'attractivité de
de ces métiers moi je crois pas que le
le pour régler ces problèmesl on doit
faire venir des gens venus d'ailleurs
des pauvres pour faire des métiers que
l'on ne veut pas faire et qu'on
recommencera dans une génération ou deux
générations parce que sinon c'est sans
fin et par ailleurs on ne parle pas
aussi des progrès de la technologie de
la robotique qui pour certains métiers
éventuellement pourrait remplacer
aisément des bras venus d'ailleurs voilà
quel proj quel projet on va RER vousêt
contre la technologie non non mais bon
c'est vre projet on va on va robotiser
l'aide à domicile pour surtout éviter
qu'il y ait des humains ven criminit
très très très rapidement sur ce lien
entre immigration et délinquence par
exemple sur ce lien entre alors changeer
de sujet à chaque fois sur le lien entre
immigration et délinquence c'est un fait
les étrangers sont surreprésentés dans
les statistiques de la délinquence
est-ce que ça signifie que le fait
d'être étranger ou d'être immigré c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose euh
engendre de la délinquence quand vous
regardez un petit peu les études qui
sont faites vous vous rendez compte que
dans la population étrangère vous avez
une surreprésentation des hommes jeunes
des hommes pauvres des jeunes pe
diplômés qui sont des facteurs qui sont
associés à plus de délinquence et quand
vous isolez ces facteurs vous vous
rendez compte que ce sont eux qui
expliquent la délinquence beaucoup plus
que le statut d'immigré ça c'est
difficile et ça s'explique en prenant le
temps de l'explication et c'est pour ça
aussi qu'on a besoin d'avoir un débat le
deuxième point que je voudrais signaler
c'est que il y a eu des des
régularisations massives en Italie sous
Berlusconi d'ailleurs il y a quelques
années qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en
terme de délinquence on a constaté que
ces régularisations faisaient baisser la
délinquence parce que les gens sortaient
de l'économie au noir ils n'avaient plus
besoin il n'avaient plus besoin parce
qu'ils avaient un titre de séjour et un
travail et bien de commettre des délit
va bien en Italie c'est pour ça
que bien sûr mais enfin ce sont vos
alliés politiques donc vous devriez
aussi assumer un petit peu ce qui se
passe en IT sur un progrès sur un pret
contre l'immigration pour dire que il
faut aller untit peu au-delà des idées
reçues et des propos de CAF pense qu'il
faut sortir des postures euh il y a
incontestablement un certain nombre
d'étrangers en situation irrégulière qui
occupent des objectivement des enfin des
des métiers sur lequel un certain nombre
de nos concitoyens ne veulent pas aller
il y a une popérisation de cette
situation ça n'est pas acceptable donc
il faut en sortir on peut parfaitement
comprendre que pour dans des conditions
très particulières déterminées par la
loi c'est ce qu'on a prévu euh on puisse
régulariser d'ailleurs pour un temps
limité au demeurant parce que le temps
est limité et euh permettre que les
choses se régularisent ça permet quoi
bon d'avoir des gens en situation
régulière c'est sûr mais d'avoir voir
aussi des rémunérations qui soient au
bon niveau avec les protections sociales
qui vont bien ça veut pas dire que il
faut accepter tout le monde n'importe qu
ça veut dire qu'à côté il faut une
stratégie politique en matière
migratoire et tenir l'entrée sur le
territoire et tout ce qui est irrégulier
et bien évidemment on ne on on on
renvoie dans les pays d'origine et on il
faut être intraitable là-dessus c'est un
ensemble la politique migratoire ça
n'est pas un un sujet puis un autre puis
un autre c'est un ensemble et c'est une
stratégie globale c'est ce qu'il faut à
tout prix comprendre sinon nous n'y
arriverons jamais ouais et et et la
question c'est est-ce que on peut le
régler la régler au niveau français oou
est-ce qu'il faut élargir au niveau
européen je vous propose de d'enttin
Quentin cal Metet sur sur ce thème on va
parler grâce à Quentin rebonsoir Quentin
de la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle sur l'immigration qui
était faite ici par le groupe LR au
Sénat le président du groupe LR Bruno
retaillot a décidé de la retirer
pourquoi c'est un revers pour les
républicains oui c'est ça elle devit
être examinée aujourd'hui ça a été
annoncé hier les retirent effec
effectivement ce texte qu'il portait
pourtant depuis mai dernier
effectivement une proposition de
modification de la Constitution avec H
articles dont deux qui faisaient
particulièrement polémique on va aller
voir s'afficher tout d'abord il y avait
un référendum élargi aux questions
migratoires et un deuxième article qui
permettait de déroger aux règles
européennes à propos du premier des deux
sujets le référendum écoutter Bruno
rotao sur notre plateau il y a quelques
semaines il faut permettre aux Français
de se déterminer pour deux raisons la
première raison c'est que il y a pas un
phénomène qui est autant bouleversé
depuis un demi-siècle la société
française sans que les Français n'est
jamais été consulté puis surtout les
résultats d'un référendum s'imposent au
Conseil constitutionnel la semaine
dernière cette proposition de
modification de la Constitution été
examiné en commission et le cœur du
projet de loi n'a pas été adopté les
deux articles qu'on vient d'évoquer 2 et
3 est-ce qu'on peut parler d'une forme
de crise au sein de la majorité
sénatoriale effectivement Thomas oui au
Sénat on a assisté à un désaccord majeur
je cite au sein de la majorité
sénatoriale composée des LR mais aussi
des centristes les centristes ont
refuser de voter les deux mesures que
j'aiévoqué tout à l'heure l'article sur
le référendum et celui sur les
dérogations au droits européens déjà on
avait vu que pendant l'examen du projet
de loi immigration les deux alliés il
est fallu et que et bien il s'entendent
ils s'entendent la veille de l'examen de
l'article 3 pour que le texte au Sénat
il passe mais donc là effectivement
c'était c'était trop pour les Alliés
centristes et écouter le sénateur loi
kvé il est revenu notamment sur le fait
que les centristes ont refusé la
dérogation au droit européen cette idée
des républicains consistant à dire que
le droit européen pourrait être un droit
remis en cause nationalement c'est
quelque chose qui nous heurte dans nos
convictions profondément européennes et
quand nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec
l'Union européenne autant mener les
combats au niveau de l'Union autant
mener les combats dans les instances
européennes que ce soit au Parlement que
ce soit au conseil que ce soit à la
Commission pour que que là dans ces
instances là le vrai débat est lieu donc
c'est cette tentative de réinverser la
hiérarchie des normes et complètement
antagonique de ce que les centristes ont
toujours porté dans la vie politique
voilà on comprend les centristes qui
n'était pas d'accord avec ce texte venu
deslr il y avait eu ce désaccord en
commission le texte allait subir le même
sort en séance aujourd'hui les LR ont
donc préfér retirer leur proposition de
modification cons et d'ailleurs pardon
si on regarde à l'Assemblée nationale il
y a eu à peu près la même la même conf
c'est ça exactement cette proposition de
loi était inscrite dans la niche des
républicains c'était jeudi à l'Assemblée
nationale dès le départ géralde
dararmanin a fustigé le texte venu de la
droite le ministre a parlé d'un double
frxit avec cette proposition un frxit
Européen et constitutionnel l'ambiance
était assez tendue en séance écoutez le
ministre de
l'Intérieur la promesse que vous faites
à travers l'adoption de ces h articles
reprendre le contrôle sur politique
migratoire pose un certain nombre de
problèmes votre proposition de loi
propose de rompre avec notre tradition
constitutionnelle et Bou vererser
l'ensemble des écrilibres
institutionnels excuser du peu c'est
sans doute ce qui a pousser la
Commission du des lois du Sénat à
supprimer ces articles hier voilà
l'examen avait commencé à 11h le matin
jeudi dernier mais rien ne s'est passé
comme voulait les alr multiplication des
amendements de la gauche vote pour
supprimer des articles à 20h Olivier
marlex a mis fin à l'examen en retirant
déjà le texte il donit certain qu'il
n'ait pas être adopté en tout cas c'est
bien un revers politique pour BLR la
séquence de ce qui s'est passé autour de
ce texte entre desunions avec l'allié
centriste au Sénat et échec de la
proposition à l'Assemblée nationale
merci beaucoup Quentin François Noël
buffet je reviens vers vous peut-être
pas on va pas parler de de l'équilibre
entre LR et et les centristes ici au au
Sénat et plutôt du fond est-ce qu'il
faut déroger au au droit européens
pouvoir reprendre la main première chose
il y a pas de crise dans la majorité
sénatoriale je voudrais rassurer tout le
monde il y a un M de panique pas du tout
première chose deuxième chose sur le
fond il y a y a un manifest justement
une appréhension qui est différente
entre le groupe LR et et l'Union
centriste et d'autres collègues
d'ailleurs pas les seuls à la fois sur
les dispositions de l'article 11 leur
modification et le fait d'élargir le
référendum possible à d'autres sujets
que ceux prévus par l'article 11
lui-même ça fait l'objet d'ailleurs des
discussions de Saint autour du président
de la République qui lui-même au départ
était volontaire pour pouvoir élargir le
prisme et finalement ensuite et revenu
en arrière il y a pas d'accord làdessus
le parti est pas venu à la dernière non
je polémique pas làdessus ouis mais
sur sur le droit européen c'estàd sur
l'article 3 sur cette idée de bouer
constitutionnel qui permettrait de
protéger la France d'un certain nombre
de décisions ou de remise en cause de
décisions qu'elle pourrait prendre qui
pourrait toucher à sa
souveraineté je pense que la question
mérite d'être posée rappelez-vous il y a
quelques années l'idée de l'Europe de
vouloir imposer les 35 heur à nos
militaires français par exemple c'est un
exemple il y en a d'autres donc ça il
faut quand même qu'on se pose des
questions ça ne veut pas dire dans ma
bouche en tous les cas ça ne veut pas
dire qu'on sort de l'Organisation
européenne qu'on quitte les institutions
europénesé à l'UM ça veut dire non mais
ça veut dire que en matière de
souveraineté il y a des sujets sur
lesquels nous devons rester maître ça
n'est pas scandaleux que de dire ça la
question est de trouver le l'outil
juridique qui nous le permette c'est
tout allez votre avis làdessus Mélanie
Vogel est-ce que c'était une forme de
frexit le fait de absolument alors deux
chose
premièrement la France a souverainement
adhéré à l'Union EUR
démocratiquement décidé de faire parti
de l'Union européenne qui est un système
politique dans lequel nous avons des
institutions qui prennent des décisions
qui s'imposent à nous personne n forcé
la France à devenir membre de l'Union
européenne donc mettre en dissonance la
souveraineté nationale et le respect des
règles européennes n'a aucun sens
puisque la France participe au conseil à
décider sur les directives il y a des
députés européens élus en France donc
c'est souverainement que la France a
décidé d'appliquer les règles
européennes la deuxième chose c'est que
moi ça me fait qu Mme bien rire de voir
les républicains qui pendant des mois
nous ont rabâé les oreilles avec le fait
que la France insoumise voulait déroger
désobéir au traités européen et là il
voulait inscrire dans la Constitution la
désobéissance au traités européen c'est
hallucinant et si on avait
adopté si on avait adopté cette
modification constitutionnelle de fait
de fait nous nous mettions en retrait
des règles les plus fondamentales de
l'Union européenne même la Pologne et
même la Hongrie sont pas allés jusque là
Marc ferci est-ce que effectivement le
risque c'était de placer la France dans
la dans le même j'allais dire le même
sac en tout cas la même famille que la
Pologne ou la Hongrie non je vais pas
aller jusque jusqu'à dire ça en revanche
je partage je partage effectivement la
préoccupation qui a pu s'exprimer
notamment par l'Union centriste ici sur
une forme d'inversion de la hiérarchie
des normes je pense que la rédaction
même si je ne vais pas mimisser dans les
dans les discussions qui ont pu avoir
lieu en commission des lois au Sénat
mais il me semble que la rédaction
ouvrait la possibilité euh de déroger de
manière quand même très très large un
certain nombre de principes europé et
puisque est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on
peut euh garder la main sur le flux
migratoire sans déroger au droit
européen parce que c'est ça la question
qui justement il me semble que les
bonnes réponses sont européennes elles
sont européennes elles sont dans euh ce
qui figure aujourd'hui dans le pacte
asile immigration euh elles sont euh
dans un certain nombre de réponses qui
engagent des moyen à l'échelle
européenne c'est en particulier le cas
de Frontex et puis euh j'entends
évidemment les les l'exemple qui a été
donné tout à l'heure qui a beaucoup
choqué cette histoire d'imposer les 35
heur à nos militaires cet exemple a
trouvé une réponse une réponse de nature
politique puisque nous sommes revenus
là-dessus parce que nous avons fait
pression sur les institutions
européennes c'est la raison pour
laquelle il me semble que c'est plutôt
par ce ce type de voix qu'il faut agir
plutôt que de prendre le risque
justement bah de sortir des facto de
l'Europe em dur forcément vous voulez
prendre la parole sur oui éidment alors
pour revenir sur ces 35 heur peut-être
que les militaires ont été épargnés
c'est pas le cas des pompiers il y a un
vrai sujet un vrai sujet
mais restons sur la
question migratoire et Fran exemple je
vais citer une fois n'est pas coutume un
ministre de la majorité monsieur
Darmanin il y a quelques jours a voulu
expulser un oubec fich s radicalisé
jusqu'à l'extrême il l'a expulsé c'était
une bonne chose à faire pour protéger
les Français qu'a dit la CEDH elle a dit
vous n'avez pas le droit d'expuser qui
sont ces gens c'est une organisation
européenne non mais c'est la même chose
c'est le principe normalement les les
les décisions de la cdH peuvent
s'imposer et et donc et ensuite le
Conseil d'État pour euh comment
dirais-je respecter ces décisions la cdH
a dit ok bah du coup monsieur dararmance
que vous avez fait vous n'avez pas le
droit vous devez le rapatrier et en plus
lui donner 3000 € est-ce que vous croyez
que les gens comprennent ça est-ce que
vous croyez que les gens comprennent ça
c'est juste hallucinant donc évidemment
que cette personneelà doit être expulsée
à vie et il y en a pas 4000 donc pour ça
il faut déroger au droit européens mais
évidemment
en c'est pour ça que je repose la
question parce
que C N rien àir pour
information Cour de droit euh très
simple il y a le Conseil de l'Europe
d'accord qui sont les pays qui ont
adhéré à la Convention européenne des
droits de l'homme avec laquelle est
associée une cour la CEDH la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme qui est
saisie en cas de violation de la
Convention Européenne des droit de
l'omme ça n'a aucun rapport avec l'Union
eurir à la Convention l'article 8 qui
pose problème l'Union européenne c'est
autre chose et la France en est mem et
je vous signale qu'il n'y a aucune
directive et aucun règlement jamais
concernant l'immigration qui n'it pas
été adopté au conseil sans la validation
de la France du pays du gouvernement sur
la cdH la question c'estlication de
l'article 8 et des conditions de
l'article 8 c'est là-dessus que le débat
est ouvert il y a des protections
simples des protections absolues il y a
des choses qui sont très très
compliquées à à gérer et ou sur lequel
dans les cas particuliers qu'on vient
d'évoquer effectivement c'est pas
acceptable la personne présente un der
éent donc mais c'est de modifier so soit
on rediscute les conditions
d'application de cet article 8 on on le
repose ça veut pas dire qu'on protège
pas d'autres personnes mais on repose
ces conditions on a parfaitement le
droit de le faire faut un texte he c'est
pas un coup d'État il faut un texte
naturellement ça fait partie des sujets
que on peut évoquer qu'on a évoqué
d'ailleurs à l'occasion de de la
commission la semaine dernière bon le
texte n'est pas passé les deux articles
majeurs ne sont pas passé je comprends
parfaitement la volonté du président de
de de retirer ce texte mais le sujet le
problème perdure faudra quand même le
régler mais ce qu'il faut rappeler c'est
qu'en matière migratoire on doit marcher
sur deux jambes on a un problème de
législation nationale puisque c'est
notre possibilité de faire et y a la
législation européenne la question c'est
queon a une complémentarité et pas des
handicaps c'est ça l'enjeu donc il faut
quand même que la France sur un sujet
aussi important que l'immigration comme
d'autres puisse garder la main sur un
certain nombre sur sa politique
migratoire naturellement qu'elle discute
qu'elle mène des mesures d'action à
l'échelle européenne pour que les choses
avancent on peut le comprendre mais
attention on a quand même sujet de
souveraineté réelle là-dessus allez on a
entendu vos arguments aux uns et aux
autres sur ce dernier thème merci à tous
d'avoir participé à à ce débat bientôt
sur Public Sénat je voudrais vous
remercier toutes et tous de votre
fidélité à Sens public vous donner
rendez-vous évidemment demain pour une
nouvelle émission 18h et 22h et puis
noter que l'invité de la matinale
demainian monsini reçoit François patria
le président du groupe Renaissance ici
au Sénat belle
[Musique]
soirée